[Music]
you know there is Lotte in the middle of
Ohio now you know when Seinfeld was on
and everybody loved it
guess what it's Jews from New York like
this idea that we're so out of touch and
that this culture we've come up with
here is an a thumb out of the rest of
the country like guess what this is
where we are as real American as
everybody else and sure there are more
liberals here you know sure sir we're
used to a more heterogeneous population
in New York City than what I just saw
when I was reporting in Maine last week
but there was plenty of Lotte and we're
not that different and we're not any
less American well it's also a matter of
like sorry about the facts sorry that
that big science which is to say
scientists have realized that if we keep
doing things the way we're doing them we
are going to end the world sorry I mean
I wish it weren't so like but it doesn't
make it a liberal phenomenon I mean I
just beyond my comprehension the thing I
was gonna say about the New York Times
is you notice that as much as that
president likes to say it's fake news
the minute he goes and meets with their
editors he says it's a great American
treasure you know I mean it is the paper
of record and now in in fairness they
did make some mistakes they're humans
like all that stuff around the WMDs and
the room and the windup the Iraq war
that is serious stuff that happened that
the times got wrong that eroded public
trust but I don't actually think that's
what's going on I don't think that's
what this election was about I mean we
know for a fact that it wasn't we know
for a fact that there was a very
targeted system for disseminating fake
news
long form journalism is the only thing
I've ever done write that in writing
books you know I don't know how to be a
newspaper journalist I think what they
do is incredibly impressive but I'm not
trying to do it I don't know how to do
it and they have a different mandate
than we do I mean their mandate is to
attempt objectivity and ours isn't I
mean we are meant to tell the truth and
everything you read in The New Yorker
has been fact checked more than you can
believe but the overall story I'm
telling in any given no matter what it
is it's always my version and it's not
my mandate to be to be without a
perspective it's not my mandate to to
remove myself to have the least present
authorial voice I can that's not my
mandate my mandate is to try to make it
interesting for the reader while
informing the reader you know with with
you know a complete allegiance to
accuracy but I'm allowed to tell the
story however I want to and that's the
luxury I mean that's being a long-form
that's being a magazine journalist and
that's what I love about it I'm never
I'm never endeavoring to make myself or
my point of view invisible that's not my
mandate I'm trying to be subtle about it
because the quieter and sort of you know
the more if I'm sly about it then it's
more persuasive because you don't want
to feel that someone's directed you to
think this that and the other you want
to feel that you think that but it's my
job to lead you to think whatever it is
I want you to I mean just there's I
don't think there's a it depends depends
I mean depends how honest the individual
journalist is and how much and how much
allegiance he or she has to the truth to
accuracy you know I mean I am NOT
we´d to making every person feel that
their perspective has been represented
I'm representing my perspective when I
tell a story but every single detail in
that story will be the truth and no
little falsehood is okay ever and we
take that very seriously
[Music]